well this is a big number 606 000
perhaps not as big as we're thinking but
it is a record high for a calendar year
uh politicians on both sides of the
political divide would like this to be
small they won't say the number they
would be happy with so it's worth
getting into the figures behind this
going through them and understanding
where this has come from where we're
looking historically uh in terms of this
number so this is net migration over
time it's worth saying there has been
adjustment in these figures you can see
back in 2018 obviously depressed by the
pandemic and then right up here now this
last bit is really really interesting
there was this ramp up after the
pandemic but actually the peak for
migration net migration came in
September that year that was 637 000 so
what we're actually seeing here is a
slight tailing off and you can see that
in terms of the types of visas that are
being granted by the government it's
worth saying as well as well the
government is granting these visas
you've got study work humanitarian Roots
Asylum family and other study and work
are the big ones here now when
politicians talk about reduce you seeing
this this is the problem they come up
against that big number is made up of
these still big but smaller numbers so
study work humanitarian risk now study
brings in a huge amount of money for the
treasury exports there are bigger than
Aerospace exports in terms of students
paying fees when they're coming from
abroad work a huge amount of that has
been driven by people getting Health and
Care special Visas so I'm obviously
going to the public and saying well
we're going to have fewer people working
in the NHS that's going to be tough and
then humanitarian risk this is people
coming from Ukraine coming from Hong
Kong coming from Afghanistan we know
according to polling that these are very
very popular so that is the tricky bit
with this in terms of well how do you
reduce that number even if you're
getting rid of something like family
numbers which has been proposed that's
not going to make a huge dent in that
but then the other side of that going
back to that graph where we saw it
slightly tailing off what we are
starting to see is some of the effects
of immigration people leaving the
country uh compared to immigration here
so when it comes to study we saw that
big bounce back after the pandemic
people couldn't come here perhaps they
were doing online courses they changed
that they were able to come here so they
got that Visa what we're starting to see
in statistics already some of those
people who were here in December 21
arriving they've started to go home
that's expected to increase over the
years and then when we go to work visas
they were created to create uh to fill
these shortages we saw in the NHS that
we reported on all over the last year a
lot of those jobs have been filled
there'll be less of them and the same
with Ukrainian visas especially we saw
15 000 people applying a week at the
start of that that's now down to one
thousand so there is hope
um if you're from the government side
that this will continue to come down
it's certainly not going to be in the
tens of thousands though and the other
questions you know this is six hundred
and six thousand that is the equivalent
of the size of Glasgow nearly in terms
of the population added to the UK you
think of all the infrastructure that a
city like Glasgow has hospitals schools
houses is the government doing enough
about that in terms of infrastructure so
people talking about that number whether
it should be higher or low in future but
that is the number today the other
question should be is there the
investment to make sure that's a
comfortable accommodation